the woman fell to the ground clutching
her ankle in pain it had crunched badly
as she'd fallen and now as she looked
down at it she could see that it was
bent totally out of shape the heavy
metal collar choking her neck made it
difficult for her to catch her breath as
she tried her best not to hyperventilate
the rain was hammering down so
ferociously but she could barely see
more than 20 feet in any direction but
she didn't need to see far to know how
deadly of a predicament she had found
herself in she cried out at the top of
her voice for someone to come and find
her anyone but the only sound that
filled her ears was the wild howling of
the wind and the steady hammering of
water into the bog all around her she
would get hypothermia and die no wait
she couldn't could she she knew she
couldn't die but she also knew that she
was still capable of suffering just how
bad would it feel to be in the clutches
of hypothermia with a broken ankle and
know that no matter how bad the pain and
suffering got she would never feel the
release of death she closed her eyes
trying her best not to think of the
worst possibilities just as the sound of
gunfire erupted in the nearby buffer she
cried out again holding both hands up in
the air doing the best she could around
the heavy metal collar but no one
shouted out in reply there was a pause
in the gunfire maybe they'd heard her
maybe they were trying to figure out a
way to come down and rescue her crack a
bullet split open a rotted tree trunk
just a few feet to her right the woman
threw her hands over her head and
cowered in the dirt feeling the metal
over collar digging into her skin
tighter than ever please don't let it
happen again she prayed silently into
the dirt encased in the collar around
her neck for 4.5 kilograms of plastic
explosives each with a fragmentation
layer pointed inwards towards her neck
and head with just a push of a button
they could she didn't want to think
about it all she knew was that she
couldn't let that happen to her again
looking through eyes bloodied with tears
and Rain she saw it lying in the dirt
just a few feet away from her that
infernal machine that was the sorry
cause of all of this the SCP Foundation
has long stood as a Bastion of Hope
information and security for the
entirety of the human race I'm sure you
are well aware of the number of world
destroying catastrophes that have been
averted by the hard-working researchers
agents and other members of the
foundation all without the general
public having the slightest clue that
something was amiss with
state-of-the-art holding cells all over
the globe and the sharpest Minds
Humanity has ever produced working
around the clock to ensure the
protection of humanity it is hard to
imagine an entity that should not be
contained by such a group and yet one
such entity does exist scp-00
001 you may have come across the o5
council by this point while the SCP
Foundation operates beyond the world's
jurisdiction the o5 council operates
beyond the foundation's jurisdiction the
rules methods and protocols that are the
Cornerstone of securing containing and
protecting countless entities around the
world sometimes cannot be applied
certain entities require us to
temporarily abandon our Humanity abandon
our sense of order and step briefly into
chaos for the greater good I'm telling
you all of this because
scp-001 is not held in a containment
cell there are no keypads locked doors
observation windows or health and safety
forms
scp-001 is not confined to a specific
territory or even a specific country for
some scps this is a practical necessity
serpents that are hundreds of kilometers
long swimming through the depths of the
ocean for example but for scp-001
it serves a more psychological purpose
the Scottish Highlands are the most
remote part of the United Kingdom out
there you can walk for miles and miles
without seeing a single soul open
Countryside mountains locks and forests
around you in all directions the weather
is Harsh and unrelenting the walking
even more so on a regular basis Walkers
fall and break their legs but without
phone service or anyone else nearby to
come and help they can quickly disappear
into the Wilderness forever the peat
bogs of Scotland used to see human
sacrifices in early settlements afraid
of the ghosts and spirits that haunted
the bogs people would throw their family
members into the deepest parts and watch
them drown hoping that whatever was
lurking beneath wouldn't come and find
them so as the group of soldiers crested
the top of the mountain and looked down
beneath them to the Eerie peat Boggs
obscured by mist and constant rainfall
you would forgive a shiver running up
their spines but of course it didn't
that was because this group of soldiers
were quite unlike any others that
Humanity has ever produced all were
nameless none of them existed on any
government databases on any foundation
databases or even on the databases of
the o5 council itself their individual
backgrounds nationalities and families
were totally unknown to everyone other
than themselves some had been tortured
for years others had been the torturers
the thing that United them however was
their inhuman ruthlessness a squad of
eight soldiers utterly devoid of any
sense of empathy what could they
possibly have to be afraid of in the
peat Boggs when they themselves were the
evil ghosts walking through but then one
person was afraid a shiver ran up her
spine as she looked over the edge and
down into the murky black and green
below scp-00
001-1 around her neck was the bomb
collar each of the eight soldiers
surrounding her had a button mounted on
a watch on the back of their wrists at
any moment any one of them could hit the
button and all four and a half kilograms
of plastic explosives would go off
sending her on an Express trip to
Oblivion aside from the collar she wore
a plain white dress made of cotton it
was muddy and torn apart at the Hem from
Days of walking through the Scottish
Wilderness when she had first arrived
she had begged those around her to
supply her with some warm clothes
something practical that would keep her
comfortable and Stave off any illness
her requests however had not been
acknowledged clutching in her trembling
outstretched hands was the machine
scp-001-a from its external experience
you would think it was nothing more than
a wooden box a perfect cuboid made from
glossy dark wood there were no symbols
no seams no latches nothing to indicate
any method of operation when the woman
in the machine had first been delivered
into the hands of the o5 council the
researchers had spent weeks and millions
of dollars trying to activate the
machine their best scientists had
scanned for every possible form of
radiation and tried every method they
could conceive to stimulate the box into
opening the ultimate failed attempt
involved traveling to North Korea where
they negotiated placing the Box 20
centimeters beneath a small nuclear
warhead in return for granting the
dictatorship key information on how to
construct such a weapon as we have
established the o5 council operates
Beyond any kind of jurisdiction yet at
the bottom of the irradiated crater set
a perfectly intact wooden box that was
cool to the touch and showed no signs of
radioactivity only one person could
interact with the box and unearth the
secrets that were inside
scp-001-1 the woman who stood Treme
tumbling on the side of the mountain a
gun jabbed her in the back forcing her
to continue moving she had asked the
soldiers around her how much longer they
had to walk that day but none of them
had replied they never did in the six
years that she had been held hostage by
this tiny militia she had never once
heard any of them say a word not even to
each other perhaps it was this
telepathic understanding that seemed to
run between them that unnerved her the
most despite having never spoken to each
other each Soldier seemed to understand
the others intimately and she had no
doubt that any one of the eight would
press the button on their wrist at a
moment's notice sadly for her she knew
this from experience the incident
happened four years ago now as the group
was traveling through Patagonia it was a
day almost identical to the one she was
having now they had been transported by
a helicopter flown by one of the eight
into the middle of the Wilderness there
they had marched for days without saying
a single word exhaustion had overtaken
her legs and she stumbled to the ground
unfortunately for her this happened
slightly too close to the female soldier
in front of her her knees hadn't even
hit the ground before the blast went off
the woman didn't remember it of course
how could she in an instant her mind had
been utterly destroyed what she did
remember was the next 18 months as her
body slowly healed itself one brain cell
at a time it wasn't so much like waking
up from a nightmare it was more
constructing a nightmare slowly
alongside your Consciousness as neuron
by neuron your brain reformed itself
each individual cell screaming in Terror
at what had happened to it they had her
marching again before she was fit to
move her motor controls had been all
over the place she had fallen over
regularly and the terror of having one
of the soldiers push the button again
engulfed her with every movement and yet
Perhaps the most incredible thing about
scp-0 001-1 was the fact that if you had
asked her if she should have been held
in this kind of containment she would
immediately have agreed without batting
an eye the only person capable of
opening the box she recognized how
dangerous her existence was only she had
seen into the mysteries of the Box only
she had seen the horrors laid inside of
it and so only she could fully
understand the gravity of their
situation they kept her on the Move in
order to keep the world safe had she
been held in a containment cell she
would have posed too great of a risk out
here in the wilderness the entire planet
was her containment cell hidden in the
middle of Humanity's biggest Haystack no
one not even the o5 council's Central
Command knew her location the only
people who were aware of it at any given
time were herself and the eight soldiers
surrounding her with guns drawn so you
can imagine her horror when out of the
Sheets of Rain appeared the figure of a
person carrying a rifle the gunfire
broke out before
scp-001-1 even had a chance to hit the
ground bullets whizzed through her hair
and cracked open the Rocks all around
her the eight soldiers surrounding her
die for cover as the figure in the rain
slumped to the ground lifeless one of
the soldiers grabbed the woman by her
explosive collar and threw her behind a
rock clasping her hands over her ears
she closed her eyes and waited for the
fight to be over no one was shooting
until a second figure emerged from the
rain waving their arms wildly gunfire
again she wasn't quite sure what had
happened but all of a sudden the woman
was falling down the cliff she'd just
been trying to shift her position to get
deeper into cover but she clearly hadn't
noticed just how close to the edge she
was down and down and down she fell
until with a crack in her ankle she
landed in the peat bog gunfire cracked
on the mountain above her but the only
thought that filled the woman's mind was
the terror that at any moment the
explosive collar around her neck would
be detonated as one of the soldiers a
buffer realized that she was missing
seconds passed as the fear mounted in
her chest with each passing moment the
anxiety grew more and more crippling she
had to know she had to prepare herself
if it was about to happen she had to use
the machine and look into the future
dragging herself forward through the
muck the woman snatched at the wooden
box it came alive at her touch different
pieces shifted and opened beneath her
fingers like some kind of elaborate
puzzle no one had taught her how to use
this thing it just happened her fingers
would just dance across its surfaces
pushing and pulling opening and closing
twisting and turning and locking into
place until all of a sudden there it was
the box was wide open in front of her
taking a deep breath and allowing the
rain to fall on her head for another
brief moment the woman leaned forward
and stepped into the box on the trail
above her the gunfire stopped without a
word of communication the soldiers had
definitely flanked the group of people
who had approached them in less than a
minute they neutralized each individual
that came their way in unison the group
of them walked up to the bodies turning
them over to examine their faces they
were nobodies just a group of hikers
lost in the rain what had looked like a
gun turned out to be nothing more than a
walking pole five of them in total none
of them older than 24 without words the
soldiers picked up the bodies and threw
them over their shoulders as they
scrambled their way down to the cliffs
to the woman in the machine beneath them
once they reached the bottom of the
slope they discarded the five bodies
carelessly into the bog within a couple
of hours those five hikers would have
sunk to the bottom and begun the long
process of being embalmed Into the
Depths perhaps someone would find them
in a few thousand years time as part of
an archaeological dig perhaps but it was
not their concern the eight soldiers
surrounded the women gun drawn and
stared at her coldly I use the machine
she told them I used it without your
permission I I don't know what the rules
are I don't know if we even have any
rules here but I thought you should know
the soldiers continued to look at her in
Silence the box was closed now sitting
back on our lap as it always was I I try
to see my future anytime I've used the
Box before I've looked at the lives of
others I've seen economic crashes
climate disasters genocides Wars love
and life and death I've done so at the
hands of the o5 council as Dave told me
giving them the information and
prevented the destruction of the world
never once have I looked at my own
future the soldiers lifted her to her
feet and tried to March her onwards not
listening to a word she was saying her
broken ankle buckled and screamed
beneath her she had to hop to keep up
with them what other choice did she have
they would push the button if she didn't
she didn't know why she kept talking but
she did For the First Time The Machine
lied to me I saw that I was assassinated
in 1987 in Cuba was years before I even
built the Box before any of this
happened to me I saw in my future that I
no longer existed that the machine no
longer existed but that future was years
ago and none of it happened the machine
doesn't lie so why is it lying to me now
why can't I see my own future if any of
the soldiers were paying attention they
didn't show it they just continued to
March her into the rain as the bomb
weighed heavily around her neck now go
check out scp-001 the children or borrow
cycle and insane scp-001 fight gate
Guardian vs Scarlet Kang